là où ça bouge à fleury-sur-orne c'est
vendredi on retourne à l'école primaire
avec les cm2 mais pour faire du théâtre
on essaie d'aller le plus vite possible
l'école jean goueslard accueil de
classes d'enseignement théâtrale cours
de chant et de théâtre complètement
segment général de ce et cm 2 ce qui est
intéressant à cet âge là c'est qu'ils
sont extrêmement séparés ou justement
dans l'essex
les gars ont un côté des filles de l'eau
dont tout le travail des premières
séances c'est vraiment de mélanger les
garçons filles ont fait tout un travail
de tirage au sort ce qui fait que les
groupes constitués le sont vraiment par
hasard alors qu'au départ ils sont très
réticents ces fans se mélanger le fait
du tirage au sort ça passe
et donc qu'ils acceptent petit à petit
de se mélanger et ça c'est déjà un atout
formidable
ensuite il faut qu'ils puissent se
touchent et qu'il puisse jouer à
s'attraper vraiment avant des actions
concrètes sans faire mal donc c'est le
respect du corps de l'eau l'harmonie du
groupe
c'est vraiment un travail de groupe à
cet âge là l'objectif n'est pas de
monter un spectacle à la fin de l'année
d'aborder les thèmes du répertoire
classique forcément je travaille cette
année sur un texte de littérature
contemporaine d'eugène durif qui est un
auteur français contemporain elle fuit
ce n'est de froid sur cette route dr
c'est renfort s'abattent dans sa main
non c'est trop triste merci en fait on
est obligé de leur donner un petit peu
des clés pour pour toucher du doigt
l'objet théâtre avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de jeu les
inscriptions pour la prochaine promotion
de théâtre à horaires aménagés se font
jusqu'au 15 mars auprès du conservatoire
de caen ou de l'école jean goueslard de
fleury sur an il faut préparer quelque
chose faut préparer un petit un petit
programme
alors si je suis une fiche de
renseignements et puis le 31 mars tous
les enfants qui se sont préinscrits et
bien viendront assister des ateliers
théâtre pour voir s'ils ont une
appétence ils ont envie voilà
envie de pratiquer et puis aussi et puis
il y aura un petit entretien avec le
individuel apprendre à faire du théâtre
et commencer dès l'école
c'est quand même magique merci beaucoup
4e édition d'art quand les arts à caen
avec comme invité d'honneur cette année
alain pauzié un artiste singulier très
particulier qui expose ici au saint
sépulcre
c'est gratuit magnifique
il fait partie des cinq mutisme des
singuliers avec un petit bémol et il
fait et récupère et transforme les
choses il ordonne à une autre
orientation à l'autre sens mais un petit
bémol j'irai ya toute une grande
intelligence d imposer une véritable
écriture il à la fois singulière ici
avant tout pour moi un très grand pas un
ch'ti siens et je pense que jean
dubuffet l'avais bien ressenti comme ça
quarante ans du travail d'alain position
décliné au saint sépulcre de caen parmi
ses oeuvres les bons à rien galles et à
visage humain
disposés en foule dans l'exposition ces
bons à rien ils naissent de rien et
quand je vois ces voiries aujourd'hui je
suis pas sans penser à tous ces migrants
qui meurt dans la mer parce que bon
c'est complètement d'actualité
l'exposition alain pauzié est à voir
jusqu'au 27 mars au saint sépulcre deux
camps de trois quarts
jazz dans les prés c'est à la ferme
culturelle du bessin ce soir dans le
cadre de focus jazz un peu partout
pendant un mois en normandie
votre concept c l'itinérance cessa 27
dates cette année qui sont non change de
village en village 27 communes qui sont
concernés donc ce soir la scène
culturelle du bessin pour la soirée
inaugurale demain l'église de drieu et
après demain la salle des fêtes de saint
pierre du regard pour notre premier
concert dans l'orne avec un formidable
harmoniciste c'est ça olivier ker ourio
accompagné par trois musiciens bas
normands puisque c'est le concept en
invités avec des musiciens locaux
est ce qu'on écoute en ce moment c'est
la bande originale de touchez pas au
grisbi et j'ai d'excellents
d'harmoniciste d'allouer aussi avec
didier lockwood michel legrand ou marcel
azzola j'ai beau lire la révérence ben
oui yens